une bande dessinée en hommage aux
habitants de clamecy ceux d'aujourd'hui
mais aussi avant tout à ceux du 2
décembre 1851 qui se sont opposés au
coup d'état de louis napoléon bonaparte
3000 personnes dans la ville quatre
jours où la ville est prise par part
s'est insurgé 23 barricades sont petites
villes on vous imagine et
l'effervescence pendant longtemps ça a
été des oubliés de l'histoire
mais là depuis un certain temps de
nombreux historiens ont fait revivre ce
moment important où des hommes des fins
de la république d illustration réalisée
par le dessinateur edmond baudoin où les
clamecycois d'aujourd'hui ont aussi leur
place à travers des portraits et des
messages d'espoir abdel fait partie des
habitants qui ont participé à l'aventuré
c'est vrai que se retrouver comme ça par
le plus grand des hasards sur une bd sur
une histoire qui va marquer qui va être
racontée bien au delà de clamecy alors
on est un petit peu touchés émus et en
même temps très flatté aujourd'hui les
jeunes les enfants des scolaires pour
pouvoir apprendre de l'histoire de comme
si la résistance à 36 je pense que c'est
très important en tout cas pour
l'histoire de comme si pour les
générations à venir une histoire et un
festival qui font de clamecy durant
quelques jours la capitale de toutes les
formes de résistance invités majeurs du
festival
christiane taubira qui prône l'égalité
pour résister aux extrêmes l'égalité est
une ambition forte qui se traduit par
des droits qui se traduit aussi par une
relation c'est à dire le souci d'agir
ensemble donc la résistance et là on
prend toute sa place notamment lorsque
le monde traverse une perte de grande
morosité de grands périls et où les
sociétés risquent de se disloquer
à travers ses expositions conférences et
projections le festival se veut porteur
d'espoir en démontrant que toute
initiative positive peut faire changer
le monde